this is a production of Cornell
University
let's talk about genomes so Frannie said
she when I met her just a little while
ago she said she likes to work with
things she can see and so you know who
wants to work with DNA what you can't
see so the problem of seeing the DNA is
really important for understanding how
the genome works and so we're talking to
talk about data visualization so before
I start I'd like to just some of you may
have missed it but in the beginning of
September there was a major scientific
advance 30 publications were published
simultaneously in science nature and
other journals which is fruit coming out
of the encode project and the latest
phase of the encode project and so this
was a paradigm shifting outcome and it
says something about the genome which
I'd really like to communicate to you
the leader of this this vast consortium
of scientists something like several I
think over a hundred scientists were
part of the consortium over a hundred
million dollars spent on this it's
basically phase three of the genome
project and once you have a genome you
have to figure out what it's doing and
so they've been trying to understand
what what the genome does this is what
the leader of program said he said the
genome is a jungle of information it is
multi-layered and multi-dimensional and
the tired genomes are mostly functional
a major major paradigm shift in terms of
understanding of the genome and so the
bottom line is that not only does it do
we usually think of the genetic code you
know the code that goes from DNA to RNA
to protein well that only accounts for
one to two percent of the genome there
are many other codes many many codes in
the genome many languages and they
overlap and if you ask a computer
scientist if they could write
overlapping code they would just you
know their eyes would go cost so this is
this is a amazing reality but it it
suggests that understanding the genome
will be the challenge for the people who
raised their hand who were born before
1980 this is that generations challenge
to figure out what in the world is going
on
inside the genome and what they've
discovered so far most people
acknowledge is just the tip of the
iceberg so how do you try to even
approach all this new data I just like
to tell you about what data
visualization is it's an area of science
it's here's the bottom line the best
pattern recognition software in the
universe is our brain and so you can
program a computer to look for a pattern
but it'll only look for the pattern you
asked it to look for
whereas our brain everything we look our
brain automatically recognizes patterns
and so that's that's something that is
unique to the human brain they still
haven't developed a computer that can
recognize a face for example so data
visualization is the is it involves the
process of making data visual and when
it's visual then our brain can take over
and easily recognize patterns and that's
the origin of this program called
skittle and so if you look some of you
have seen genomic data and it's just
endless AST c's and g's and you will
find that your brain can't really you
know when you look at a few million of
those your brain doesn't see any pattern
if you do something as simple as adding
color to the scheme you can start to see
patterns and so skittle the first first
dimension of skittle is simple
colorization of nucleotides and so i've
suggested now for the people in geneva
I'm just going to take a minute and show
them some live running of the program
and I'd be happy to share it with you
when I'm back up in Geneva maybe next
week but bear with me just for a moment
and I'm going to escape this and close
this and I'm going to pull up a skittle
program whoops that's not the one I
wanted there it is okay so this is maybe
maybe the people in Geneva can see this
but this is a display of 40,000
approximately 40,000 pixels and each
pixel represents a nucleotide so that
this is chromosome 10 of corn and the
first pixel is green meaning it's a
guanine okay so you're looking at 40,000
letters but because it's colorized you
can start to see patterns and so over
here the way skittle works is there's
basic settings at the top you can
determine the width of this you can
determine the zoom in and zoom out you
can do just determine ghost's zoom to
any starting point you want there's ways
of bringing in new data like from a
genome browser and there with there are
basic functions that will be can be tied
to your mouse and then over here there
are different displays so right now
we're looking at a simple nucleotide
display so this is raw data this is the
data it's just that the data as a genome
as a FASTA file colorize so the let me
just show you the gray our uncie Qin
snaps so let's just see what we can do
here one of the things we can do is we
can change a dynamic diameter you can
perhaps see that I'm making it narrower
and if I close if I change it enough you
see a new pattern so basically these are
tandem repeats and if I said I love you
I love you I love you I love you that's
a tandem repeat and if you have a line
break after the you every time all the
letters if I love you I love you will
line up and you'll get these columns
straight up and down columns right so
that's what you're seeing here is a
tandem repeat and this is a large tandem
repeat and it's throughout the corn
genome it's especially abundant in the
centromeric region and it's but it's
throughout the genome it may represent
five or ten percent of the genome so
it's a major element and if I told you
talked about 10 and repeats without a
visual
you wouldn't immediately get it when you
see a picture of it it's really obvious
isn't it
okay so that just I'm going to jump back
to the PowerPoint for the sake of the
people at Geneva but but perhaps that is
helpful to you
okay so people of Geneva I'd be happy to
just ask me and I'll show you how the
skill works later okay this is a picture
of the corn genome and I like it because
it shows a couple of things that are
very significant one is it shows the the
very different nucleotide percentages
there are areas that are gc-rich
and there are areas that are 80 rich and
sometimes you have areas that are
cytosine rich they're mostly red and and
so you have it's not you might picture
it as a uniform blend but actually
there's these huge variations this these
areas that are gc-rich
are where the genes are so these are
genic regions and if you look really
carefully you'll see a tandem repeat
here and a tandem repeat at the
beginning of the end of this gene so
let's just look at that a little more
carefully this is a similar tandem this
is a similar genic region and you can
see there's a couple of things one one
is it's gc-rich another thing is that if
you look really carefully in here you'll
see a texture which is called a which
which we call a three mer pattern but
that reflects codon preference in other
words you can recognize protein coding
regions okay I'm sorry I haven't
explained what this new display is this
is the repeat map so if you have a light
colored pixel here that means that a
string this long has repeated once if
you have a series of pixels here that
means you can see it correlates with
this repeat here where these are lining
up so this is a very very sensitive map
of repeating units within the genome and
it's it's much more sensitive than any
other genome tool for detecting
repetition within the genome and what
you see here very carefully if you look
really carefully is there's a pattern
with dark dark light dark dark light and
that pattern is throughout the genome of
all organisms and it represents the
nature of the protein coding
the quota and preferences and what's
significant here is that there's a
tandem repeat at the beginning and the
end of the genic region and so that
means that those tandem repeats this is
something you find throughout the corn
genome it is but in thousands and
thousands of places in the current do
you know it means normally people have
always thought that 10m repeats are junk
DNA they're just mistakes that happen
during DNA replication but what we find
is that these are strategically at the
beginning and the end of these genic
regions so they're not junk they're
they're precisely where they're supposed
to be and they always match they come in
pairs they can't represent at the
beginning and the end of the exon the
coachee protein coding region the other
interesting thing is it's a little bit
off scale here but we we can look at
where the annotated exons recognized
exons are and most of the things we see
with skittle have never been described
before in other words they've been
invisible to the normal gene searches
and so we're seeing a functional units
within the genome that weren't visible
using other technologies for analyzing
genomes so this is an example of a
similar similar genic region it's a very
8e rich you recognize it right away
right it's very distinct here you can
see the the texture that I spoke of can
you see that texture in the back that's
that's very distinctive of protein
coding regions and then you can see here
this is called an exon track this is
these lines are just marking where
there's a protein coding exon and what
you see is in this case this exon has
been identified by previous researchers
as a functional gene genic unit but 99%
of these structures that we see have not
been identified previously as exons so
we have a new way of identifying exons
in any genome which is very sensitive
and very exciting just it's more of the
same you can see a GE Creegan that's
what I call bracketed by tannin
repeats and the tandem repeats again are
these are these repeating units so
that's that's really exciting here's a
closer look at the tent that this
texture and you can actually see that
the the greenish yellow the bla needs
are lining up because this is a very
non-random this is the exon okay we know
this is the exon we can see that it has
the exonic signature and we can actually
see the in the raw data we can actually
see that there the third nucleotide
tends to always be a G yes yeah I'm
sorry I should have expressed that it's
like a book so you go to the end of the
line and go back to the beginning so
it's raster
so yes okay so this display length is 88
thousand nucleotides are present in this
picture right here out of three billion
so so you'd have thousands and thousands
and thousands and thousands of pages
like this so you can i've spent just
looking at one chromosome you can spend
hours and just get a few highlights of
that chromosome so there's a huge amount
of data this is again what we one of the
things we can do is we can if we see a
tandem repeat here we know there's a
tannery he'd be here because here's the
repeat map so now we have a new display
if we click on the first nucleotide of
that line what happens is it will take
that line and search the whole genome
for that sequence and color wherever the
foot you find it so this is basically
just showing that yes this genic region
is flanked by ten and repeats at both
sides and the fact that it's the same
color means it's the same sequence so
you can search this is a similar one a
different flanking sequence and now
we're going to jump to grape so that's
just a the reason I used corn to begin
with is that's the only plant genome I
know of where I have the exon track data
where people have actually figured out
where the protein coding regions are but
let's just consider another
horticulturally important crop in that
is the grape genome and here again you
can see very distinct tandem repeat now
you see there are variations within the
tandem repeat and the question that
could be asked is that noise like
mutations or is that actually
information these patterns often remind
me of again
ancient history when we had punch cards
for a computer analysis so and you can
see how the repeat map very easily
detects this and also the how the repeat
map is telling us that right here there
is an exon so visualization data
visualization as a powerful tool when
you're exploring the unknown this is
just more 10 and repeats some of them
are you know very conserve some of them
are broken up is that by design or by
mutation I don't know
right right
good good point so this the repeat map
finds these repeats instantly and
regardless of your frame width you have
to find you have to bring this red line
and you see the red line might have been
here I brought it over to the over the
white first white line and that tells me
number one it tells me that this is a
sixty six base pair repeat it's sixty
six base pairs from here to here and
then I can set the width and then
everything lines up and I can see what's
going on so we do have a function which
I didn't while we were live I didn't hit
the alignment cylinder display but
basically it takes the ten and repeat
and turns it into a coil and then
adjusts the coil width to all the tandem
repeats are visible we actually believe
that tandem repeats coil in the nucleus
and so they form like solenoid like
structures and that that's what these
repeats are all about so this is a just
a striking component of if you zoom out
so you're looking at a whole grape
chromosome what you see is this 66th
base pair repeat is massively throughout
the center of this chromosome like just
millions of nucleotides are are just
coding for this repeat so okay this is
the same repeat actually showing the the
solenoid display and so you can see we
believe that this is not in nature it
can't rester that the rest ring but you
know this is a nice 2d display but this
is meant to be a 3d display we can make
that spin and we can we believe this is
the actual structure in biology
it just keeps coiling because it DNA it
turns out wants to align with its own
similar sequence and so the logical
thing for a repeat is to form a coil so
this is again an in grape showing we
don't have it there's no published exons
to my knowledge for grape but we would
predict there's an exon here almost
certainly an exon here
and I possibly exons here the blue line
is a strength indicator and when it goes
to purple that means bingo you've
definitely had an exon so just more
evidence of exons
a little more the same so I'm just gonna
keep moving because you know I could
show you as ilion's of pictures I've
mentioned that there that wasn't some
thought these are just a few snapshots
of the genome but the tomato genome is a
sim another horticulturally important
crop where they've completed the genome
and assembled it and what you see here
again is there's some strange repeats
here which are fuzzy they're ill-defined
we have the three Mir pattern which is
very strong indication that there's
protein coding here and then and then
these other ones are possible exons
since exons only represent one to two
percent of the genome it's critical to
be able to identify where they are more
potential exons and showing some of the
larger tandem repeats that would be you
know these really big wavy repeats that
I show you there's a name for that it's
called alpha satellite DNA and and so
all plants and animals when you see the
wavy pattern you know you're looking at
alpha satellite DNA after all higher
organisms show this wavy pattern and oh
I know I want to go back for a second
you'll see that there's a region here
that's got more red and green and versus
the other blue areas so this is a
gc-rich region so it's a potentially a
gene and again you'll see it's bracketed
by a tandem repeats so the same pattern
we saw in corn is showing up in tomato
and to my knowledge as Penner has never
been seen before and until I've seen in
the last few months as I've been looking
at plant genomes more so this is this is
the idea of data visualization is it
will show you patterns the computer
wouldn't have spotted what we see is
these things come in pairs and they tend
to bracket protein coding regions what
are they doing we don't know but it
gives us reason to wanna
do research on that a lot of things are
actually repeated so there's a lot of
repetition in the genome so that's more
of these bracketed areas you see this is
uh this is an important clue as to
what's going on in the genome and none
of these have been annotated so it's all
you know it's really showing us things
about the genome we wouldn't have known
without it
then the rice genome this is really a
pretty picture it's a picture of the the
centromeric alpha DNA of the DNA of rice
and I'll just show it quickly because
rice like corn the monocots are really
have really different genomes they have
them there you just notice the color is
different there's much more red and
great greenish yellow and much less blue
so when you're in the dicots
everything's bluish and everything's
orangish when you go here we've zoomed
in so you can see a little more
specifically the patterns that are
occurring within the deviations within
the tandem repeat and there's some
interesting things that are going on
here that would be worthy of exploration
and you can see here in greater detail
it goes a dark column a dark column a
light column a dark column the dark
color lake home so you can see more
clearly what's what what the three
murder display is was telling us telling
us every third nucleotide is similar to
the three to the one that was three
nucleotides before it and that's so
basically the lighter the pixel the more
the similarity averaged over the whole
string so another thing that is a major
feature of genomes that we're seeing is
the every other pattern and this is
basically black and blue alternating
sprinkled with with greens and reds and
so we have no idea what that is but it's
throughout plant and animal genomes so I
don't doubt for a minute that it's doing
some
thing this is just more evidence of
exons in rice this pattern is very
strong and you can also see the gc-rich
and you can even see the alignment
things are lining up here partially
because the because of this pattern is
very very strong
it means it constrains most of the
nucleotides in the genome a lot of us
you know we've been taught that most
nucleotides are just drifting and they
don't matter most nucleotides you know I
have a function and therefore need an
explanation
more more exons just really rice is
really really strong signal ok so that's
that's the kind of a quick overview of
what plant genomes look like when
they're visualized with skittle skittle
is a program that's in development in
fact some of these features the feature
that measures the where the exons are
the strength of that signal was just
it's just two days old so it's just I
emailed me at the latest to revision so
it's all still being improved but what
we believe we have here is a universal
genome browser now some of you know what
a genome browser is but basically if
you're looking at you know let's say 3
billion letters and you're trying to
figure out what it all codes for you
can't just look at the letters and so
they've made genome browser does it help
you spot where the genes are help you
analyze where the junk or the repeat is
and other types of you know
understanding about how the genome is
operated we feel that skittle is the
foundation for developing all those all
those browsers are one-dimensional their
strengths and so this is a
two-dimensional display two dimensional
analysis and began it lets us we believe
it's the next generation of genome
browser and that this week when we get
skittle fully developed we can annotate
and recognize every feature within the
genome in a way that's fundamentally
better than genome browsers today so
we're excited about that and it's
already I think very
fruit in terms of giving us new insight
into plant genomes and other genomes but
I wanted to add just briefly some work
that my colleague Josiah seaman did on
his own so Josiah Siemens is you know a
computer scientist I have to dig rest
for a second so I was I was never
interested in computer science not even
a little bit and and so I looked at as a
necessary evil I mentioned that you know
I was the last one in our department to
switch from the typewriter to to a
computer for word processing and then
when email came along I absolutely did
not want to be bothered by email
I was absolutely the last person in our
department to finally connect to the
email so it's really funny to me that in
the last 10 years I've played a role in
developing what I think are the two most
exciting bioinformatics programs
available and of course the reason is I
had the good sense to partner up with
some really brilliant computer
scientists because I'm still practically
computer illiterate but but Josiah just
says one of those people and he
developed all the programming that went
into this and it turns out that you can
look at any patterns with skittle like
you can look open up any text file you
can open up Moby Dick and see what the
pattern is you can also open up computer
code so the way he found out he could
open up code was when you start skittled
it asks you what file you want to open
and he forgot that he had already opened
skittles sweet used skittle to open the
skittle executable code that makes sense
and he immediately saw some really
surprising patterns so it turns out that
skittle can be use for analyzing
executable code and that's machine
language that's something no computer no
computer scientist almost no computer
scientists can read machine language so
this is the first time we actually
skipped to look at the computer code I
don't have the that would make a really
interesting talk but I just want to give
you some highlights from what he saw
this is Moby Dick so there's no no
pattern no nucleotide base this is the
repeat map there's no significant amount
of repeats I'd be pretty boring wouldn't
have to same chapter twice in a row so
the genome for decades has been called
the book of life but we assert strongly
that the actual genome has no physical
similarity to a book and a book is
passive but a computer program is active
and runs it's alive so here's what we
this is a zoomed out version of a1 one
of these is executable code zoomed out
so you look at the whole code maybe
60,000 bytes of code and the other one
is a zoomed out so you can see most of a
chromosome which one is code in which
one is X which one is genome they both
have these these these major shifts in
color change so in DNA we would call the
in chromosomes we'd say these are I so
course where you have a change in the
use of where the use of the nucleotides
changes in a fundamental way well it
turns out that computer code does the
same thing but we actually know what
causes these shifts in color see we know
how computer code works but we don't
know how genomes work and the fact that
we're seeing similarities means we could
use one to understand the other when you
have a change here they're going like
from pearls to Fortran it's computer
it's when you change languages you
change your letter use profile right
these these are clearly language changes
and these are in genes of the genome are
most likely changes to one of the many
you know there are many languages in DNA
yes sir
the computer code is zero zero is a zero
why we need two bits to get the four
color scheme the book was I think
actually we had 26 colors yeah but they
were our shades that your eye couldn't
distinguish so so in terms of these
changes in letter use computer code and
and he's looked at other executable code
other than his own program we've opened
up lots of and it's pretty Universal
pattern then he looked at again we're
zooming out so we're looking at a whole
chromosome this is what's called the
repeat map but on a higher scale so here
we have for example a long stretch of
red which means that a short repeat less
than 20 base pairs long is repeating and
it's repeating for thousands and maybe
tens of thousands of letters here just
this huge repeat and so you can map
where all these repeats are in a
chromosome and you see they tend to be
all you have to be near the beginning
well it turns out that the computer code
is also filled with repeats and for
example here would be another stretch of
read that also is a 10 to 20 character
repeat and you'll see that which one is
if I asked you if I hadn't already given
it away you wouldn't know which one was
a computer code and which one was the
genome would you and so if we look
closer at these repeats which of these
repeats is plant repeat and which one is
from computer code this is plant it's a
computer so the the tandem repeats in
computer code are incredibly similar to
what we see in plants amazingly similar
so here's the interesting thing as for
decades people have seen we have known
that there are these tandem repeats and
they said obviously repeats are junk
well are there repeats in computer code
junk are there is there a single bit in
a computer code that's not func
so it's strong I suggest these tandem
repeats aren't here this isn't a
coincidence its reflects functionality
and that the we actually know what these
repeats are for these are data files
like phone directory would be a data
file the first this would be like some
universal thing like telephone number
and then people have different numbers
so data files in computer code give you
this perhaps these are data files so
these another element of plant genome is
that there are called what are dispersed
repeats you know you can have repeats
where they're head to toe or you can
have the same repeating element all
throughout the genome and so these these
would be called these would be plant
this would be like a transpose ax below
element and these would be words that
are common within the computer language
so you can actually you know write in
any sequence you want and it'll look
through through the script and find
wherever it occurs so you can find out
how abundant certain words are so word
structure use or transpose opponents are
very similar within code and within
genomes so the bottom line is what he's
seen is that genomes and executable code
have amazing similarities they both
usually linear strings of code they both
use multiple languages they both use
parallel processing which means you know
you can have lots of genes being reading
at the same time like lots of processors
in your computer they both have a strong
character bias where the total color
shift occurs they both use extensive use
of recurrent tandem repeats they both
use commonly dispersed repeats or words
they both use large-scale localization
of the repeats near the end or ends of
the program and they both have passive
and active information a book just sits
there you can read it or not a program
runs and it's self changing
self-modifying so all of this is
assistant with a trend within genetics
more and more genomicists are saying the
genome is executable code and that's
really better understanding than the
idea that it's an instruction manual and
so it's just really exciting to see that
Skittles strongly supports that and it
goes from assimilate or an analogy to
actually a something we can measure
where you can actually measure the
features that are in common so I just
like to conclude I believe there are
deep hidden there's deep hidden beauty
in the genome and so I've gazed at these
colorful pictures for hundreds of hours
and it's really cool the genome has many
levels of structure we've only detected
a small fraction of it the nucleotide
bias is very strong which is interesting
because blue group blue black areas
wanna mutate to red green and red green
areas want to mutate to blue black so
it's very hard to imagine how to create
or sustain those biases ten repeats it's
clear because they bracket the genes can
carry information they are not
necessarily junk ten repeats can we can
we show can LOD would logically form
into large coils which might have
function we see ubiquitous tumor and
three more patterns which three mer
seems to reflect codon bias protein
coding bias and then there are many
levels of order
still waiting to be found and higher
genomes are most like computer code
that's that's the bottom line of what
we've been learning the last few years
using skittle that's a good place to
stop
you
well the one connection I would suggest
is that there's communication at every
level you know from the molecules to the
cells to the tissues to communication
between organisms and then of course
there's the brain function which is all
kinds of levels of communication there
so information is at the at the heart of
21st century biology it's all really
about information science and and
everything is integrated at a level that
blows our mind and so it's very hard to
conceive of how that integration could
have ever arisen and so it's just a
really interesting question but I think
more and more people are gonna be asking
is biology is much more fantastic than
we ever imagined and so it's just a real
it makes it exciting to be a biologist
in the 21st century right so basically
for data visualization you have to be
creative and in presenting the data in
new ways to the human brain their human
brain works by methods we have no idea
but when we do see a pattern like I'm
seeing this pattern where I have a what
looks like a large coding region that
has not previously been identified as a
exon and I see it's bracketed by tandem
repeats and I realize that's a highly
ordered structure and what Josiah points
out is he says skittle is for
discovering the pattern but then you
have to write special computer code to
analyze the pattern so now we can go
back and ask the computer to find every
instance on that chromosome where that
pattern happens that's the next step for
that research
it's it's available free of charge you
can download it anytime it's really easy
you know it's a really easy to
understand how to use it but it will
continue it's being updated almost
weekly so and actually Josiah's just
introduced a feature so if you're online
and using skittle and he updates it
there little thing will come up on
skittle that says update now and you'll
get the latest version so he realizes
that it's gonna be under rapid and
continuous improvement so so they don't
have there's nothing like skittle no one
has a program like skittle I wish they
would take notice of skittle what they
haven't I think as we actually this corn
pattern that I described when we show
that we use skittle to discover that
which I which is I think a major feature
of the corn genome then people will say
oh I guess maybe I should look into this
skittle business because it is a
powerful tool to just see what's going
on and also for teaching if you were
teaching genome to students we need to
show them a ste season geez it doesn't
sink in but with skittle actually you
can start to see oh I see what's going
on here this I start to see the
different types of organization within
the genome I think it's both a research
tool and a great teaching tool yes we
basically upload any FASTA file and it
it basically the first thing it does is
just colorize the letters that's really
simple but as soon as that happens you
start to see patterns then it allows us
to change the width or zoom in and out
and it allows us to put up the repeat
map or the cylinder display or several
other display options so but the raw
data is that colorful screen and you're
actually looking at the genome when you
look at that just like you are seeing
looking at a fast file but it's a lot
more interesting than a fast file
so so the repeat map takes the first
line whatever the width is it reads the
first line and then compares that to the
this to the one nucleotide over the line
that represents the next nucleotide over
and then it compares that first line
with every other possible alignment on
in the view and then for every alignment
it gives a score for the similarity and
decides how bright the pixel should be
for that spot so it's a it performs a
massive calculation each time you move
the screen to recognize all the possible
similarities between the first string
and all the other parts of that display
so that this the display pattern the the
repeat map which is the black and the
gray the grayscale that actually doesn't
change as you change with it is it is
just measuring the repeats so you'll see
those repeats regardless of the display
and then the cylinder display finds the
best alignment it's a regular display
you have to manually adjust the width to
get those nice visual patterns of the
tandem repeats
with
so there's this the 66 murder that I
found in tomato
what's also in corn yeah there's there's
and and when you find a repeat you'll
find that it's a family of repeats
throughout that chromosome and all the
chromosomes of that species there are a
few repeats are novel they're they're
they're like words they're doing
something and and they and they're found
in many different places in the genome
so basically as as we discover these new
layers of information we would like to
have it like you know how old-fashioned
overhead transparencies you could put
several on top and they you could see
how they all line up we'd like to have
skittle have transparent pages somewhat
you know you can adjust the transparency
so we can see where the exons are we can
see where the transcriptional factor
binding sites are we can see where the
histone binding sites are we can see
where the fold folding motifs are
because there's layer upon layer of
information and the only way is to have
layered a layered display so that's the
next that's in the works
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu